good afternoon my name is Kirsten
Osterberg
and I'm a sophomore here at Hillsdale
studying biochemistry in Spanish is my
pleasure to introduce you to dr. Ronald
ray - dr. ray - is a professor emeritus
of history at the City University of New
York in an adjunct fellow at the Hudson
Institute
he's also writes for a regular blog for
pajamas media his articles and reviews
have appeared in National Review The
Weekly Standard the Republic the New
York Times and the Los Angeles Times
among many others he's author or
co-author of several books including a
safe-haven harry s truman in the
founding of israel which won the gold
award in 2009 from the Washington
Institute for Near East policy for the
best book written on the US and the
Middle East his other books include a
memoir commies a journey through the old
left the new left and the left / left
Spain betrayed the Soviet Union in the
Spanish Civil War and red star over
Hollywood the film colony is long
romance with the left please join me in
giving dr. radisch a warm welcome
thank you so much have you just opened
my water first and I'm the only start
since I learned from that terrific talk
Peter Robinson gave whether somebody's
gonna have to clean up the glass not me
Peter I learned for Peter Robinson
sensational talk last night that Ronald
Reagan loved a good joke and this has
nothing to do with my talk but I could
not resist since i have a captive
audience with this joke and we get to
the end of it it's a little shaggy dog
story you'll see its applicability to
today a cowboy named bud was overseeing
his herd in a remote pasture when
suddenly a brand new BMW advances
towards him in a cloud of dust the
driver a young man and a Brioni suit
Gucci shoes Ray Ban sunglasses Eastland
Laurent tie leans on the window and says
to the cowboy if I tell you exactly how
many cows and calves you haven't you
heard
will you give me a calf bud looks at the
man obviously what today's what we used
to call the yuppie looks at his
peacefully grazing herd and he says sure
why not the yuppie parks the car wipes
out his Apple Mac computer connects it
to his singular RAZR v3 cell phone surfs
to a NASA page on the Internet
then he calls up a GPS satellite to get
an exact fix on the location which he
feeds to another NASA satellite that
scans the area in an ultra-high
resolution photo the young man opens a
digital photo in the latest version of
Adobe Photoshop exports it through an
image processing facility in Hamburg
Germany within seconds he receives an
email on his Palm Pilot
that the image has been processed and
the data stored
he then accesses an MS SQL database
through the ODBC connected Excel
spreadsheet with email on his other
Blackberry and after a few minutes he
gets a response
finally he prints out a full-color
full-color 150 page report on his
hi-tech miniaturized HP LaserJet printer
turns to the cowboy and says you have
exactly 1586 cows and calves that's
right
bud says well I guess you could take one
of my calves he watches the young man
select one of the animals and looks on
with amusement as the young man stuffs
it into the backseat of the car then bud
says to the young man hey if I can tell
you exactly what your business is will
you give me back my calf the young man
thinks about it and says okay why not
bud says you're an aide in the Obama
administration the young man says well
that's amazing how did you guess that
bud says no guessing required you show
up here even though nobody called you
you want to get paid for an answer I
already know to a question I never asked
you used millions of dollars worth of
equipment trying to show much show me
how much smarter you are than me and you
it's clear you don't know a thing about
how working people make their living or
about cows for that matter because this
is a herd of sheep then bud then walks
over to the car opens the back door says
now give me back my dog
thank you
and I'm sure President Reagan would have
loved that one my talk today is called
Reagan in Hollywood how the left came to
fear quote a very dangerous man in
celebrating life of Ronald Reagan a
great deal of attention has been
centered on the question of what events
in his life caused him to become a
conservative some have mentioned his
career as a spokesman for GE and the
awareness he gained from touring in the
plants of factories about the workings
of the free market and capitalism but
the historical record shows that Ronald
Reagan's transformation from a wartime
and post-war liberal one who was even
involved with communist front groups
during the years of the Popular Front
came during the struggles he engaged in
with Hollywood's communists in the labor
movement as well as those who were
writers and directors and actors in the
film community Reagan himself made this
clear in his July 4th 1960 letter to
playboy magazine publisher and editor
Hugh Hefner who had written him
inquiring about his views about
communism and Hollywood and the
blacklist the 50s he changes mine Reagan
told Hefner as a result of a long
process it took seven months of meeting
Communists and communist influence
people across a table in almost daily
sessions he wrote while pickets related
in front of studio gates homes were
bombed and a great industry almost
ground to a halt it was his first expand
experience with the Hollywood Reds as
they called themselves which led him to
question his old assumptions and break
with the herd mentality of the Hollywood
left it's a process akin to that taken
in our own time most recently by the
playwright and screenwriter David Mamet
who I think I was told is coming to
Hillsdale Ronald Reagan moreover was a
member of the Screen Actors Guild and
eventually its president his experience
made him an expert on the issues facing
the film industry including that of
cantankerous labor relations
in 1941 when he first became an
alternate on the screen actor guild
board of directors his first one at Jane
Wyman quipped to the organization's
executive director quote my husband
might be president of sag one day who
knows he might even be President of the
United States as the Cold War began in
the late 40s and the decision of the
House Committee on un-american
Activities began to shed light on
communism in the film colony Ronald
Reagan would play an instrumental role
as I mentioned he actually belonged
himself to some communist front groups
the main one was called the Hollywood
independent Citizens Committee of the
arts sciences and professions commonly
referred to as a CASP in later years
Reagan would say that the pronunciation
of the group's name sounded like the
COFF of a dying man in July of 46 Reagan
filled a vacancy on her caste board and
was surprised to find that many members
of the seventy to seventy or so board
members were members of the Communist
Party David Reagan join and stay in even
after finding the truth about who
controlled the organization as he
explained I was blindly and busily
joining every organization I could find
that he thought would save the world
moreover he saw that the Reds were high
on the Hollywood hog but seeing them as
liberals and being liberals ourselves we
bedded down with them in his letter to
Hefner Reagan noted he had cast his
first four presidential votes for FDR
and his fifth for Harry Truman my
interest in liberalism and my fear of
neo-fascism he wrote led him to join
hick-ass board and eventually he would
form an anti-communist caucus within the
group that included James Roosevelt
Dorrie sherry Olivia de Havilland and
others it was at one of their board
meetings the issues at hand came to the
head
first FDR son James expressed his
concern that to refute the charges that
the group was a communist front they
should issue a statement of opposition
to communism to reassure the public at
that moment the musician and clarinet
player
Artie Shaw stood up and offering to
recite Joseph Stalin's 1936 Soviet
Constitution proclaimed it is more
democratic than that of the United
States Shaw was followed by another
Hollywood screenwriter who said that if
war ever broke out between the United
States and the Soviet Union he would
volunteer to fight for the Soviet Union
at that Ronald Reagan had had enough as
he chastised his fellow liberal board
members they began to shout epithets at
him
fascist capitalist scum and of course
the two ultimate ones witch hunter and
read Bader now let's turn for a brief
moment to one of Reagan's colleagues the
great character actor sterling Hayden a
war vet who courageously had broken
through the German blockade to bring
supplies during the war to Yugoslavia
'sons Hayden who had joined hick-ass and
after returning to the States from his
action in the war he joined the
Communist Party only to quit it in
dismay six months later when he was
subpoenaed by the committee in 1951
Hayden explained he had come to realize
that the Reds quote fight for social
justice was and is a sham a mere facade
to attract people like myself who had an
honest and sincere desire to do
something worthwhile Hayden told the
committee he saw firsthand how the
Hollywood communist tried to paralyze
the industry with the goal of creating
one big union for everyone in the
industry like that of the CIO unions in
manufacturing plants unions he hoped or
they hoped would be controlled by the
Communist Party what stopped the
Communist from attaining that goal the
committee asked his struggling Hayden he
answered quote they ran into
Regan who was a one-man battalion and
indeed he was first Regan attended the
anti-communist caucus of a CASP and met
with Olivia de Havilland producer Dorrie
sherry and others as the meeting went on
Regan started laughing after he heard de
Havilland start speaking she turned to
ask him what was so funny nothing he
answered except I thought you were a
communist until tonight that is Regan
the help to her draw up a statement the
group would make at the board meeting it
would be innocuous innocuous until the
very end
and then would read we reaffirm our
belief in free enterprise and the
democratic system and repudiate
communism as desirable for the United
States obviously no pro-soviet communist
or fellow traveler would ever sign such
a statement when the anti-communist
group met with the other pro-communist
board members all hell broke loose
wagging his finger at Regan the party
boss in Los Angeles screenwriter John
Howard Lawson shouted this organization
will never adopt a statement endorsing
free enterprise and repudiating
communism a two-party system is in no
way necessary or even desirable for
democracy Reagan responded they submit
the resolution to vote by secret ballot
of the membership and Lawson replied the
membership is not sophisticated enough
to make such a decision so they sent it
only to the executive committee which
they dominated at the committee
executive board meeting de havilland was
the only member present who was
anti-communist and cast the only I vote
on behalf of the resolution that evening
she and Ronald Reagan and the other
anti-communist resigned from the
organization the same kind of issues
arose in the Screen Actors Guild of
which Reagan would become president
one-fourth of its membership opposed any
anti-communist resolution Robert
Montgomery and George Murphy called for
condemnation about fascism and communism
the two major totalitarian ideologies
Ragan has had joined the board in 46 and
he concluded that many of sags members
held strange beliefs and were unwilling
to take stands against extreme
ideologies speaking to one group in 1946
he made it his first anti-communist
public speech he got huge applause when
he condemned racists and fascism but
when he denounced communism his audience
he found remained silent
at any rate by mid 1946 he wrote light
was dawning in some obscure region in my
head I was beginning to see the seamy
side of liberalism too many patches on
the progressive coat were of a color I
personally did not care for many
liberals he said had ideological myopia
that prevented them from acknowledging
who was a communist and who was really a
principled liberal and thereby
comprehending with the private
pro-moscow agenda of the communist was
one of the major events that helped move
him away from the left was the wartime
and post-war strikes that began in March
of 1945 stopped for a while
resumed in September of 1946 and lasted
for three years of constant turmoil the
Hollywood communists had their own
private goals the first the communist
screenwriter Dalton Trumbo wrote was to
figure out how to use art as a weapon
for the destruction of fascism racial
bigotry or economic oppression or a
drive to war to attain that goal he said
Industrial Workers had to be organized
on a trade union basis and they had to
be able then use film for progressive
verbis for purposes and not hand over
movies to the use of reactionaries and
conscious fascists in real life Trumbo
and the read screenwriters lived in a
far different world than that of
rank-and-file electricians stage hands
set costume designers projectionists and
others who kept the film industry moving
nevertheless the Communists always spoke
about extending the hand of solidarity
to the real workers their opportunity
came when they saw as a new class
struggle the strikes in the film
industry
in reality it was simply a matter of two
different AF of L craft unions
contesting for the right to represent
so-called backlot employees the
mainstream labor group initials were AAA
TSE and the left-wing pro-communist
union was the CSU the conference of
studio unions led by a man named Herbert
Sorrell a secret member of the Communist
Party they went and strike as I said in
1945 curtailing all filmmaking at Warner
Brothers 20 20th Century Fox and
Universal an October 5th Hollywood woke
up to what was called the Battle of
Burbank 800 pickets went to the Warner
Brothers gates using knives and clubs as
police responded with tear gas a dozen
people were injured fire hoses swept
them off their feet others were hit by
tear gas bombs and the fists of union
activists were pummeling those who
attempted to get to work again in
September mr. Sorrell called out his
troops to again try and extend the fight
by full 846 however the Cold War was on
in earnest the California AF of L state
convention found eight unions demanding
that Sorrell and the CSU be investigated
as a stooge and tool of the communist
parties designed to destroy AFL unions
in Hollywood by that time the CSU had
support only of hick ASP and the
Communist Party the Communist facing
defeat would lose control of the labor
movement in Hollywood writing about the
strike Reagan and remember as Peter
pointed out last night
Reagan was a bonafide liberal Reagan
concluded the Communists were the cause
of the labor strike using jurisdictional
disputes as excuses for their scheme to
gain control of the motion picture
industry in order to finance their
activities and subvert the screen for
propaganda he was right he understood as
did Olivia de Havilland and others that
the communist strategy was motivated
motivated by Stalin's decision to tell
his Western cadre that world war was
inevitable and that the communist
movement in the West had
oppose the United States standing my
principle Reagan joined others along
with his current sag president then
Robert Montgomery to oppose the strike
to cross the picket line and to attempt
to keep on making films Montgomery and
Reagan rode in buses hired by Warner
Brothers to take them against across the
picket lines into the studios Reagan
then decided to break into a private sag
meeting that he knew was being called by
a friend of his the actor William Holden
the meeting took place at the home of
the actress Ida Lupino whom communist
activists had asked her to host the
evening in her home a half a dozen so
innocence as they called them came to
hear a lecture about the so called facts
in the dispute led by sterling Hayden
who is still at that time a communist
Reagan and Montgomery crashed the
meeting and Lupino greeted them warmly
others of the 75 attending were
astonished and angry when they saw
Reagan and Montgomery enter the meeting
began with Hayden praising the CSU
urging that sagged stand with Shirelles
group waiting for the appropriate moment
Reagan took the floor when he confronted
as he would write one of the most
hostile audiences I ever could hope to
address sag he said investigated the
issues in the dispute and concluded that
the CSO knew strike had no merit he
spoke for 40 minutes
in spite of interruptions and boos and
name-calling John Garfield one of
Hollywood's top stars soon to become one
of the most disillusioned and sad
victims of the communist presence in
Hollywood turned to his fellow actors
and directors and writers and said why
don't you listen to Reagan he has
information you don't have Garfield's
words shocked the crowd that they
thought he was one of their camp the
well-known communist actor Howard the
Silva asked Garfield to come to the back
of Latinos patio pushed him up against a
tree and read him at the angry riot act
punctuated by jabbing thing
in garfield's face as for sterling
Hayden he admitted with Regan he
admitted match he failed to convince
others to support the strike and as he
later said I laid an egg that evening
Regan showed up took over the ground and
ground you into a pulp everyone kept
looking at me to hold him down but Regan
dominated the evening and when it was
over they told you right to your face
you were really weak and holding this
meeting did more harm than good as the
strike progressed Reagan told Sag
members in 1947 that he no longer was
impartial I am no longer neutral
he told army veterans the CSU has proved
to self unreliable its leadership does
not want settlement of the strike it
stands to gain by continued disorder and
disruption in Hollywood his action here
marked his major separation from any
remaining members of the left-wing in
Hollywood Karen Morley and actress and
secret communists labeled his statement
as opportunism pure and simple the
liberal screenwriter Philip done called
Reagan a very articulate but poorly
formed man who was obsessed with
communism and hence I used that as my
title a very dangerous man but that
speech led Regan to win the support of
the majority of the Screen Actors Guild
and to win the presidency in 1947 and as
president of sag he openly aligned
himself with both middle-of-the-road
centrists and conservatives moving away
from the previous unity he favoured with
liberals of the moderate left he had
become as the anti-communist labor
leader in Hollywood Roy Brewer put it a
fearless foe of the communists in the
labor movement with communism a national
issue it did not take long for the House
Committee on un-american Activities
commonly referred to as hue act rather
than H
appropriate to make its voyage to
Hollywood they the hearings in Hollywood
began in 1947 it started by the
questioning by the committee members of
those who would later be dubbed the
Hollywood ten referring to screenwriters
and others who were not cooperating with
the committee's investigation before
they arrived the relationship of the
communists to the studio system was
simple the Communist screenwriter Ring
Warner jr. explained it in this way
nowhere in the world except possibly the
Kremlin had there been a group of
communists with a higher standard of
living or greater community acceptance
than the writers have belonged to the
Communist Party in Hollywood one of the
unwritten rules of membership however
and it had been a polite understanding
with our employers that we would not
advertise it now my colleagues and I
soon to be called the Hollywood 10 or a
hot story and the studio bosses could no
longer engage in a policy of don't ask
and don't tell the reaction to the hue
ACK investigation was twofold the
pro-communist left responded with a
meeting called at the Beverly Hills
Hotel in which speakers drew a parallel
between America and Nazi Germany in the
early days of the Third Reich Hugh act
one of the speakers proclaimed was a
sign of incipient American fascism a new
group was then formed by liberals who
were opposed to the communist again
Peter mentioned this the Americans for
democratic action or ad a the group was
formed in 1947 to counter the
pro-communist PCA or progressive
citizens of America a front group that
was created to lead the movement to
draft Henry a Wallace in a run for the
presidency and a third-party ticket
which he would do in 1948 ad a members
included Hubert Humphrey the Labour
leader Walter Reuther Eleanor Roosevelt
head of the NAACP Walter White the
theologian Lionel
nobuta Nibiru and a new recruit Ronald
Reagan who joined its ranks right after
it was created a DA endorsed the
Marshall Plan rejected any domestic
alliances with communists condemned the
Soviet Union and called the Soviets the
primary threat to the Peace of the world
they considered Reagan to be one of its
key persons in Hollywood the state
chairman of a DA in Los Angeles was his
friend Melvin Douglas and he joined
Douglas and others on the organizing
committee when Hubert Humphrey came to
visit Hollywood in 47 Reagan was among
the 50 who met to greet him at a
cocktail party sponsored by a DA in
Douglas is home when you I came to town
a DA condemned this investigation asking
for cultural freedom and due process
under the law criticizing what they
called hue ex interference with the
creativity after creating an atmosphere
not hospitable to the arts a DA Reagan
told his leaders offers the only voice
for real liberals I look forward to the
time when it can be of more help to the
group when Reagan testified before the
committee in open session his testimony
was in many ways an example of the
approach of all the anti-communist
liberals and a DA in an interview with
the gossip columnist Hedda Hopper he
told her our highest aim shall be the
cultivation of freedom of individual for
therein lies the highest dignity of man
tyranny is tyranny and whether it comes
from right left or Center is evil
turning to the liberal movement in the
country which he said was taking the
brunt of the Communist attack Reagan
told her that there is no if we make
America a decent place for all our
people their cause would be lost that's
why they seek to infiltrate infiltrate
liberal organizations to smear and
discredit them in an op-ed column II
wrote a few weeks later Reagan stated
that he wisely did oppose indiscriminate
red-baiting unions like the one he
belong to this
bang should be on guard against the
communist he opposed communists being
allowed to be board members of unions
and argue that their allegiance was to
Moscow first and he supported all trade
union officers signing an anti-communist
affidavit that actually had become a
provision of the taft-hartley Act which
organized labor opposed in his hew Act
testimony Reagan remained a cold war
liberal the single best way to fight
communism he said was to make democracy
work the most effective way to counter
party propaganda was to expose their
lies when we come across them and as he
did in his own group prevent the Reds
from trying to run a majority of the
organization through control by a
well-organized minority the country he
said could not compromise democratic
principles and he opposed those who
favored outlawing the Communist Party in
ideological grounds and a citizen as a
citizen he said I would hesitate to see
any political party outlawed on the
basis of its political ideology we have
spent 170 years in the country and
democracy is strong enough to stand up
and fight against the inroads of any
ideology if one looks at its testimony
it's clear that to use Sidney hooks
basis for understanding the issue Reagan
did not as yet realize that the CP was a
conspiracy not simply a heresy rather
than just another political party
organized as were Democrats Republicans
or even the Socialists of Norman Thomas
the calamitous party USA was lock stock
and barrel a creation and arm of Moscow
whose leadership did Stalin's bidding
first and foremost the Communist Party's
attempt to portray itself as just
another party enabled itself to protect
its members from just the kind of
scrutiny its leaders feared and to
shield those are it was recruiting as
SPN
agents for the Soviet Union to hide
behind the rubric of being just another
group of victims of McCarthyism now what
many people didn't know at the time was
that the unfriendly communist witnesses
who were not test refusing to testify
before the committee have privately
discussed whether or not they perhaps
should openly acknowledge the area
beliefs and affiliations they decided
not to one of their lawyers as a
hypothetical question what if you were
asked by the committee whether you
favored free speech for communist Edward
Dmytryk one of the ten assumed to
cooperate with the committee said there
was a course of yes then the lawyer said
what if they asked do you believe in
free speech for fascists some people
answered yes as they had when earlier
asked about communist free speech for
communist at that point the party Chief
John Howard Lawson raised a warning hand
they took a vote a six to three majority
still said they should support free
speech
Lawson then instructed them the answer
is we do not believe in freedom of
speech for fascists we favor freedom of
speech for communists because we have to
explain what the Communists say is true
while what the fascists believe is a lie
you also have to understand this point
fascist was the term they used for
everyone to the right of them at this
point the Communist Party was saying
that Harry Truman was a fascist Reagan
on the other hand offered the ssag Board
a resolution he hoped it would adopt he
criticized the producers in Hollywood
for inquiring into the politics of its
employees and discriminating against
them on the basis of their beliefs he
said that if once suppressed them
because of fear it could affect
everyone's freedom he felt the guild had
to protect actors he said we are urged
to make ourselves lawmaker judge and
jury and to take punitive measures in
contravention of the law he's favored
not cooperating with war makers at
favoured cooperating with lawmakers but
rejecting communists policy and tactics
that ignored fair play and democracy
while he said the producers should not
deny people a job in the basis of their
belief they had a right to keep climbing
us out of office in all groups like the
trade unions and forced them to sign a
non-communist affidavit or be fired the
board defeated Reagan's resolution by a
two-to-one margin working with George
Murphy he then drew up another
compromise
he wrote that some of our Celsius
believed I was as red as the Communists
but George never wavered in his defense
of me even though I ranted and railed at
him as an arch reactionary at a special
board meeting Reagan's revised statement
was accepted and he promised cooperation
with the studio chiefs and said that
Congress alone had the power to decide
what the nation's attitude towards the
Communist Party was by the end of 1947
Reagan had moved far from the stance he
took before hew ank he now agreed with
Eric Johnston the spokesman of the film
industry in Washington DC and the
producers and told the FBI in a private
interview that he now thought Congress
should declare the Communist Party and a
legal organization as well as go on to
designate what other groups were
communists controlled and that
membership in and of itself could be
construed as proof of their disloyalty
to America Reagan in other words was
moving closer to the view that Sidney
hook took that there was a difference
between a party of heretics and a party
of conspirators so Reagan was becoming
more conservative although he still
called himself a liberal he arranged
Harry Truman's giant rally in LA in
September of 48 he campaigned for Hubert
Humphrey and he spoke on a radio
broadcast on behalf of Humphreys
candidacy sponsored by the International
ladies garment workers union Humphreys
opponent in Minnesota he said was a
banner carrier for Wall Street Reagan
blamed Standard Oil for inflation and
high
outfits and in 1950 he supported Richard
Nixon's arch nemesis Helen Gahagan
Douglas was Melvin Douglass's wife
against Richard Nixon for the Senate and
actually cut radio testimonials on
Douglass's behalf that really became the
end of his most active liberal period
Reagan would then more firmly break
between those who still still believed
and awards the wartime alliance between
communists and liberals he now joined a
group for the labor labor league of
Hollywood voters that mobilized against
the pro communist third-party candidacy
of Henry Wallace and supported Truman's
reelection they urged that Truman reject
compromise with the Communists Jack
Warner the producer wanted one of the
Warner Brothers joined the group and he
announced that from now on he had become
a Republican liberalism Jack Warner said
I think is just a disguise for communist
propaganda and he said he wanted to make
a new film that would star Reagan that
would be openly anti-communist that he
would titled up until him now
the film was don't look for it it was
never made he felt it was too political
and it would bomb at the box office so
he cancelled it Reagan also led the
fight and the other leftist front group
which he belonged to the American
Veterans Committee the second of the two
Popular Front groups he stayed in and in
here just like with the other group he
tried to organize them against accepting
both totalitarianism he said that the
AVC national organization was taking a
position curiously similar to the party
line of the Kremlin in a resolution he
wrote with Melvin Douglas
they said as we're unafraid of the
communist label both accorded us by
reactionaries were equally unafraid of
being called read Bader by the
communists we are they said non
extremists finally he became involved in
the as a founding member of a yet new
the MPIC motion picture Industrial
Council and here he joined publicly with
leading producers including Walter
Wanger dore schary
the anti-communist labor leader roy
brewer and others helping to get the
public at large to support Hollywood his
work with the MPIC
developed him as a political later
leader it gave him a national profile
brought into Washington led him to
investigate other issues including
foreign policy and constitutional issues
he was brought into contact with
political leaders in the nation's
capital and he went through the Senate
and the House meeting with people
defending Hollywood and urging them to
understand that he and others in
Hollywood's supported the loyalty to
America of actors and writers and
directors that group was unique it was
made up of the leading heads of
Hollywood guilds of the trade unions and
the producers all of them strong
anti-communist one of its leaders were
Cecil B DeMille the older Fame director
who said in a speech to the group that
the conflict in the world today was
between communism political unionism and
socialism all of which would destroy
Liberty others in the group beside
Reagan included Roy Breuer Walter Wanger
twanger and Alan Rifkin all of them who
had time been liberals but who now came
to support the position of the studio
Chiefs and urged an anti-communist
policy by Hollywood as head of the NPIC
Reagan sought to have the newspapers
emphasized that the film colony
consisted as he told them of
hard-working church-going family men and
women who engaged in more charitable
activities in any other group Reagan
attacked the sensational sensationalism
and irresponsible journalism of the
press whom he accused of emphasizing the
flamboyant more colorful exaggerated
side of things and the messy side of
things
the film industry he said was a private
industry the press ignored its rights
and journalists openly wrote stories
that tried to make us look
he singled out the gossip columnist
Hedda Hopper and others as people who
lack journalistic integrity so by the
early 1950s Ronald Reagan was on the
road to becoming conservative and moving
far away from the liberal community he
began with working in tandem with the
producers he had a new outlook he said
the following to the Kiwanis Club in the
1951 speech about how the movies related
to America Reagan said quote we are
pretty proud of the fact that our
government says that in the ideological
struggle going on in the screens of the
world it is the American motion picture
not with message pictures just showing
our store windows in the street scenes
with things that Americans can buy our
parking lots our streets with
automobiles and were shots of American
working men driving these automobiles
that is holding back the flood of
propaganda from the other side of the
iron curtain as president of the MPIC
Reagan would have the chance to win as
president of the United States Reagan of
course would have the chance to win the
great an ideological struggle and use
his power and position to bring down the
Iron Curtain and put it into the dustbin
of history but back then in 4748 v in
1950 working closely especially with
Eric Johnston the representative of
Hollywood in Washington Reagan gained
experience and insight into politics at
the national level outside of Hollywood
eventually adopting Eric Johnson's
disdain for what the industry spokesman
called the New Deal spirit of vendetta
and class warfare and the influence of
collectivist socialists communists and
super planners who look upon business as
an enemy to be destroyed talking of the
conflict between individualism statism
Johnson obviously had a great influence
on the future governor and president
and Johnson I think sounded like Reagan
did years later when he made statements
such as the one in which he said every
power vested in the state is a privilege
conferred those powers not explicitly
given to officialdom belonged to the
people Ronald Reagan's experience in
Hollywood taught him to oppose both
communism and to exalt and defend the
USA which he saw thought were two sides
of the same coin listening to a speech
Reagan gave in 1951 audience member told
the press quote Reagan made you feel
like shouting from the rooftops that you
too were privileged to be an American
because Ronald Reagan loved America and
the people who have made it the melting
pot it is today uncork America Reagan
said in that speech was nothing but the
inherit love of freedom and each of us a
system in which the people decide for
themselves America he said was a place
in the divine scheme of things that was
set aside as a promised land
so in Hollywood Ronald Reagan started on
the path to a future in politics rather
than in entertainment and it is his
early experience in Hollywood I contend
that began to move him away from the
liberalism at the start of his
involvement in politics to become one of
the most if not the most influential
conservative leader in the last century
thank you
we Glen have to take any questions you
have this was substantially cut down I
even cut out more of it today it was
written twice as long so any questions
vibration
yes
ah you didn't hear the question was one
is the mindset in Hollywood that makes
you liberal even more to the point what
was the mindset in Hollywood then as
well as now that makes so many in
Hollywood left-wing not even liberal on
the far left and I think there's a lot
of evidence for that which the book my
wife and I wrote we deal without a lot a
lot of the actors especially the ones of
that era in the 1940s came up from the
bottom and they were hard work they were
people who grew up in urban ghettos poor
Irish or Jews or whatever group they
were part of and they hadn't talent for
acting some of them learned acting in
settlement house workshops and all of a
sudden they were discovered they'd go to
Hollywood they come in Hollywood in the
period of the Depression when thousands
are out of work the country's suffering
and they're earning the most phenomenal
salaries in the world now what you have
them say over and over again is a
personal expression of tremendous guilt
that they are suddenly doing so well
living a great lifestyle buying mansions
having great cars being written up in
fan magazines and the guilt is
phenomenal one of the ways they deal
with that guilt
it's like positively responding to the
appeal made to them particularly in
Hollywood in that era by the communist
who said you may be rich you may now be
famous but your allegiance is to the
world proletariat and if you give 10% of
your income to the Communist Party you
won't feel bad anymore and you could be
aiding the struggle for communist
revolution they bought that and they're
able to go on not feeling any guilt I
think that has a great deal to do with
it and some of them have said that
themselves
memoirs and other things but that was
the principal reason they found that
very appealing
now today you know but there's a similar
psychology the other thing is that
everybody when everybody around you is
of one mindset it's very easier
that's why Reagan was so courageous to
break with the herd
everybody has one mindset your question
arises today is there a blacklist
against some people in Hollywood were
really conservative through some of them
keep it secret rather than make their
religions known they're more and more
courageously say look I don't think like
everyone else Jon Voight does that
believe Ron silver does that they began
to speak out and not no longer remain
silent but most of them you know the way
it works it's all informal as Ron silver
has said to me I can't prove there was a
formal list that said don't hire me but
I know because some people have told me
there are jobs I was considered for them
and the person who was making the film
would raise his outlaw eyebrows I said
no we don't want Ron silver they'd
rather give it to someone who thinks
like they do and have it all part of one
friendly Club rather than sully the
warders by hiring someone who thinks
differently that herd mentality is very
powerful and Hollywood in our book we
talk about the famous screenwriter and
novelist but Schulberg who wrote a
best-selling book in the 40s what makes
Sammy run and he was one of the most
prominent figures in Hollywood in the
communist movement and he wanted to
write this novel he first wrote a short
story
well the various reasons the Communists
didn't like it didn't give the picture
they wanted to be public about Hollywood
so what bud Schulberg did day in and day
out they would confront him you can't
publish his story you can't write it
don't do it
it's wrong they were threatened him and
what it was so severe and the pressure
was so great for me
his friends that without telling anyone
he and his wife bought a car drove to
Vermont rented a house without a phone
where they lived for a year or two no
one knew what happened to them no one
could reach them they didn't know where
he was and he wrote the novel knowing
that there was not going to be anyone
there to stop him from doing what he
wanted to do the only way he could do it
was to leave Hollywood and get out of
the milieu that's how strong it was
it's a coterie of people who like having
everyone think the way they think and
they like to punish those who don't
think the way they think and that's the
way Hollywood works I think it probably
works the same way now any other
questions in fact the Committee on an
American activities the the blacklist
that was being made was actually a
remarkable success for the Communists
because they portray themselves as
victim and if they if there's a story on
National Public Radio about the
blacklist
they're always speaking of that America
was and how good those communists to it
in a way so ultimately the Communists
are so so far removed from reality and
honesty so immoral that in the end they
want basically well they won the
cultural war they had narrative one of
the things true the Communists benefited
from the blacklist because it allowed
them to paint themselves as great
martyrs for free speech when as we saw
they didn't believe in free speech they
only believed in it for themselves they
some of them wanted to go out not answer
the committee's they want to hold a
press conference and come out in front
and say we are communist and we're proud
of it but we just don't want to talk
about what do we before Congress but
they were telling the public what we
really believe well that was vetoed they
were told by the Communist Party leaders
we don't want you to do that we want you
to pretend to be what you aren't to fool
people so that work with you
you're just regular liberals and they've
eat wouldn't allow them to do that so
the blacklist enabled them that they're
living it for years every few years
there's a major article movie radio play
honoring the victims of the blacklist
it never stops the last thing was the
PBS film two years ago written by the
son of Dalton Trumbo called red white
and black listed some of you may have
seen it on PBS you watch that film you
wouldn't know that Trumbull was a
hardline communist it only paints him as
a martyr for free speech never mentions
what he believed or what he said
privately the whole picture has been
distorted over and over so that people
who learn about the past learn about it
in one distorted way they never get the
real story about what happened they
never even know that later in life even
Dalton Trumbo began to turn against his
original beliefs and actually even said
the reason most of these people didn't
get jobs is not because their blacklist
is because they were lousy screenwriters
and they couldn't write anything and
enabling them to say their blacklist
made them into be the great writers they
never were I mean they said a lot of
things privately that nobody knows about
so you know that's why history is so
important the real truth of what
happened in the past is hidden from us
they've been like maybe we list them all
in the back of the book and appendix of
every film motion picture and
documentary made about the Hollywood
blacklist and they all have the same
point of view there's not one that tells
the real story and every couple of years
a new one comes out they never stop
coming
nobody has ever dared do a public
documentary or film telling the real
story in its complexity though I don't
think they've won they have
you know stray the country is
conservative it's a center-right country
we win elections the President Obama
will probably lose the election but the
cultural apparatus the NPR's the movie
industry the television industry they
remain in the hands of political
liberals and leftists and they continue
to tell the same old story in the
popular media the sort of a disjunction
the country can change reject liberalism
and leftism but those who dominate the
culture remain on the left by and large
even though there may be some actors
speaking out as I said and bravely
bucking the trend like David Mamet the
industry controls what is made I doubt
even though David Mamet is a great
screenwriter and one of the most
prolific and praised if he wrote a
script about going over this past epic
that told the truth about what the
issues were let's say film praising
Ronald Reagan's role and the way it
developed to say that couldn't it they
would never make it despite the fact
that I might have a great appeal to the
country if it's made well if they make a
good film they would not make such a
film that hasn't changed I don't think
it is going to change soon yep
over there yeah
do you think that the insights and
understandings and the struggles that
Ronald Reagan got in Hollywood were
influential in his presidency and why
the Russians were so afraid of him well
I think his expertise and knowledge of
what the Communists were really about
came from his experience in Hollywood
and it wasn't I knew when he suddenly is
present has to confront with the Soviet
Union then dealing with Gorbachev he
knew what the communists around were
about he knew what they believed he knew
what their system was like he knew how
it mouths how it didn't work he knew it
was going to collapse and he knew his
job was to hasten his collapse he had no
doubt if you look at all the people who
oppose Reagan who favored even the other
Republicans they tucked
we can't upset the applecart remember
there was a whole part even a year two
before East Germany fell there are all
these people saying we have to have us
stop us Poli polity we have to recognize
East Germany is a valid sphere and deal
with it because it's never going to
collapse there's nothing's gonna fall
it's here forever there are tons of
major writers saying that communism you
can't upset Gorbachev as Peter said last
night don't even put in a thing that
tear down the wall because they felt
that system is here to stay we have a
better Soviet leader than the old ones
who are more warlike but don't do
anything to help end the system because
that will antagonize them and get them
upset Reagan knew that you don't defend
a system that should collapse and I
think he's understanding communism came
from his experience of seeing the people
who were communist in Hollywood seeing
how they acted they were duplicitous
they lied about what they believed they
attempted to use minority maneuvering to
take over organizations in which they
were not a majority but to take them
over and control them through a small
coterie and it's the old story it's
really true you hold a meeting that
begins at 9:00 p.m. it's still going on
at midnight
still going on at 2:00 a.m. and most
regular people have jobs and they leave
with the Communists day and then they
pass the resolution when everyone else
is gone and that's the resolution that
passes that's the way they operated
they're fanatics and they had tight
control and that's the way they act
acted in groups so he knew all that as
he said he thought they were just
liberals at the beginning you know there
was the old slogan in the 30s communists
are just liberals in a hurry
they wrote just like us there were
liberals but they just wanted to move
faster
well Reagan said that I believe
communists were liberals like us they
just were a little more passionate so he
didn't think there was anything wrong
joining a group when he suddenly saw the
majority of the board of the group of
the communists and then he stopped once
you're in that level you start seeing
what they believe in what they act and
you realize these people are evil and
you pull out of the group and the
attempt to fight them so that's where he
gained that knowledge of communism the
rest of the knowledge about capitalism
and how it works
came afterwards but as I said with the
NPIC that's his first foray into
Washington DC where he meets with
national political leaders and obviously
he was driven to politics he didn't want
to remain just doing this and local
level of the film community
he had a great talent and he used it
anyone else
we have milked thank you doctor a Tosh
over here yeah
you spoke about the divide between rich
communists and poor workers communists
who spoke for the lower-class supposedly
yeah but we're not members of it
themselves how do you think this split
came about
that's a historian well I mean the
example I was trying to think of his
name the great gangster movie actor
James Cagney James Cagney is the key
example that's a major star of his day
if you have ever seen on the old
gangster movies you've seen James Cagney
he came he was the one I was thinking of
he came he was trained at a Lower East
Side settlement house in New York City
but people who put him in a feed at
Gould and said you have a real talent
for acting he got to Hollywood overnight
he was catapulted to being a major star
and the people who trained him in New
York were socialists and kind of happen
to be socialists and communists and he
was a great example as he said over and
over he felt enormous disjunction
because he had lived in the streets he
was poor as can be and you go overnight
through me just like everyone else
living in the Lower East Side he was a
Catholic Irish Catholic kid very poor
suddenly earning a fortune especially in
those days you know if you have that
same social conscience you had before
the people you grew up with are still
back there and you feel tremendous guilt
so if you get a group that claims to
speak on their behalf and all you have
to do is get them some of the money
you're earning that's pretty easy and
then you can be used by them as they did
with Cagney they brought him to appear
rallies they put them on the stage next
to leading Communist Party leaders in
California there's James Cagney on stage
Cagney speaks on behalf of the communist
that's the kind of thing they did these
people don't have any great political
understanding
I mean someone like James Cagney wasn't
a thoughtful man like we heard about
Reagan or citizens desk everyday reading
and studying and learning this is
someone who just came from the streets
without much of an education that kind
of person doesn't know much that kind of
person is very easy to be flattered and
wined and dined and used and you could
say boy now I'm using my fame for
something good because this organization
is supporting all the kind of people I
left behind I haven't betrayed them even
though I'm now rich and they're still
poor I think it's just psychology and as
sterling Hayden said it took me a while
to learn that I wasn't helping the
people I thought I was helping
I was espousing an ideology that would
make things 10 times worse for them but
you know some people it takes a while to
learn that now I have no clue in the
21st century while so many of the actors
and actresses are still left-wing and
still believe this garbage when there's
no rhyme or reason to believe it that is
a mystery
it's almost inexplicable you know what
accounts for the vitriol and the garbage
that comes out of the mouths of people
like Susan Sarandon I mean who knows
where it comes from or why they
obviously really believe it it's a
mystery
you know but there's hope let's tell
them some people people slowly surprised
us by beginning to change they may not
have moved to where we'd like them to be
but you know I saw two years ago I met
Richard Dreyfuss the actor at the CPAC
convention and had dinner with him and
he turned out to be thoughtful serious
person who's moving in new directions
just you know he may not think he's a
conservative I'm not clear if he's
confused about what he is but someone
like him wouldn't be caught dead five
years ago at a CPAC meeting so slow
the currents emerging then indicate some
people are thinking possibly for the
first time in their lives all right
thank you very much